hello and a very warm welcome to another
edition of talking Germany the show
where we do just that and my guest today
is a woman who is a remarkable person
with a remarkable name and here she is
in person Nika Wagner thank you very
much indeed for joining us today here on
talking Germany pleasure pleasure with
me too yeah wonderful
now Nicaragua has since the beginning of
the current year been the director of
the Beethoven festival that takes place
annually in the former German capital
Bonn she is also the great-granddaughter
of Richard Wagner Richard Wagner who was
of course one of the greatest and most
controversial composers of all time
Nika vogner you have a remarkable story
to tell and as I said at the beginning
you have a remarkable name and I'm going
to begin with your name Nika Wagner your
first name Nike in the English
dictionary goddess of victory yeah my
sense is that you perhaps wish that you
have had a different first name yes
already when I was a child I didn't know
what it meant but it has a harsh sound
Nika I didn't like it
later on I thought it was maybe not the
right moment to be named baptized on the
name of the Greek goddess of victory you
were born in 1945 there's there's
something to mitigate the whole thing is
that my father was a fanatic of Greek
ancient Greek culture and my sisters are
called iris and Daphne so we kind of
make a row you know yeah yeah but later
on I asked my mother when I was really
adult already what did you think
naming me Nika at the time they didn't
really think much she said they we
didn't really think we liked the name
the sound of the name and I mean things
have to become better one day okay
that's your first you never very happy
with my first name okay yes no I'm like
II unless
I saw it from the Nike from the sports
so now I can be relaxed you can be
relaxed let's talk about you your family
name yeah I mean I don't know people in
our in our audience know but vogner is
actually quite a common german name but
in your case you come from the vogner
family the descendants of richard wagner
v the the the gigantic troubled
troubling german composer yeah and I
know that somewhere you said that having
the name Varga has been for you a bonus
but somewhere else you said you think
that because people would say to you
when you were a child that you think
because your name is Varga no you're
somebody special
yeah what's you know what's is it a
bonus or a burden yeah as you know it's
always both as a child is kind of uneasy
situation at school was not was not very
agreeable you think you're something
better because you have this Magne
family well you get used to it and funny
thing is I lived a lot abroad in France
in America in England the first thing
people say when you're being presented
she's called Nicky Varna they always
think immediately that you're part of
this particular family yeah it cannot be
otherwise because that's the only Varna
name one knows mm-hmm no it's it is an
advantage in the whole of course on the
social level things are going easier
yeah I do not have to prove something
all the time you can always get me
invited without a gentleman known women
otherwise yeah you have to justify
yourself by something but if a woman
comes as a vogner she can yeah
accompanying gentleman if I said it's
nicaraguan let's go back to your very
early days you mentioned that you were
born in 1945 the year of Germany's
capitulation and the years that followed
that the immediate post-war years that
was a time of great great hardship in
Germany what can you remember of that
hardship I always wished to have some
chocolate it's very simple did you never
get the know Americans orders just
through them we were in the street as
children they gave us some chocolate so
this is very very how long how long in
your life did you have to wait until you
got the chocolate you know with the so
called the chuff's wonder the economic
miracle things got better no I hardly
survive as a child as a baby I hardly
survive which makes me quite tough for
nowadays no and no but if you're amidst
a big family you don't realize the
social misery around you you you have
described your childhood as happy and
very stable yeah surprises me because I
mean that you know that the house the
famous house van three that you were
growing up in had actually been sort of
hard-hit by it was a ruin it was a ruin
yeah but we were in a kind of resource
for a while well where I was born at the
Lake Constance I think it is in England
yeah yeah and when I was about three
years old I we went back to the
destroyed by LaVon fate but you see the
benefit of misery is that families are
closed together mm-hmm
this is why my memories and I was the
third child from for my memories are
quite happy we were all close together
much later of my parents were especially
my father you went out to me to work at
different theaters so this was kind of
splitting up later yeah but this kind of
stable feeling
to do with the beginnings of her work
and reestablishment of the barrett
festival and it was yeah like in many
other families close together and how
early did you as a young person realized
that you were growing up in an
extraordinary family your your
great-grandfather was Rashad vogner your
great-great-grandfather was Franz Liszt
that must have at some stage you must
have recognized that this was no
ordinary family no you grow up in this
family you will find everything quite
normal first signals are it's cool when
they say do you think is your something
better because your name is vogner this
is the first kind of distance signals
and much later you you begin to realize
who was her partner hmm what are the
good parts of him what are the bad parts
and what kind of heritage is it and for
this kind of reflection it helped me a
lot to be abroad it's much more
difficult all my all my siblings they
stayed in Germany I was the only one who
went out I was abroad constantly so this
helped a lot to see things from outside
tell me a little bit about your your
father
vilandra who was the grandson of Richard
Wagner and a remarkable man I know you
loved him dearly but I think quite quite
a sort of a difficult father possibly I
don't think so he was a marvelous father
because you could identify with him with
what he did kind of in the arts at the
fish fill house and this kind of
revolutionising the whole system and
being against the old Varna tradition
the Nazi tradition included was very
helpful so this gave me the sense and
when I winner all my opinions of the
Arts are still colored by the impression
my father has always in opposition at
given to us and he was a very father we
loved
children a lot and he was an artist and
you learn artists a little bit different
and children recognize this and they
adapt it's interesting to see the glow
in your eyes when you're talking about
artists maybe different from ordinary
bourgeois mean
okay so that was villain partner your
father his brother was Wolfgang Wagner
and the two of them more or less
inherited the family business by right
after the Second World War although
there have been people have been sort of
quite angry with the vogner family and
didn't necessarily want them to inherit
the family business they did your father
died in 1966 very early really and at
that point in time you were then cut off
yes from by roids and my feeling is that
that must have been one of the central
moments in your life and a painful
moment yeah you're well-informed my
father died and there came in new era
his brother came to power and it's a
very general pattern so the children of
the former chief have to be let's say
eliminated they have to be they won't
have to get out of town out of town get
out of our home villa van suite and yeah
and he made it very difficult even to
get tickets to come back to the Bower to
fish-belly so a new era began I was 20
of age then I think it was a good break
finally
but you had to reinvent yourself I sense
we all had my always talk when I say
weeds always my two sisters and I press
my brothers we all had to reinvent
ourselves
nothing was natural anymore because
usually our father would have taken us
in integrated us into the festival work
this would have been the normal line of
life so this was destroyed and cut off
both converge now my uncle did this for
his own siblings very experience
experience
the huge elements of sort of tragedies
broaden our mind also if you have note
you have to make other experiences you
get more international yeah you don't
always stick to your German surroundings
I think so
you were creatively uprooted yes you
have to invent your own profession and
you have to yeah to deal with the vogner
family with the banner image also how
did see in abroad with history okay
nikka vogner in that report Richard
Wagner is described as a genius most
people agree that he was a genius can
you describe that genius for us 33 words
330 no undeniable reception success of
Varna is incredible up to our days
you're quite right
why why this success it's not the first
time that this question has been posed I
try to do yeah make it short
maybe it's the erotic and the psycho
psycho analytical thing mm-hmm that
draws people because he is the sensual
nosov music undeniable mm-hmm and then
he has found a trick always to to depict
auto-generate archetypal familiar
situation situation everybody knows
relationship father/daughter for
instance the farewell of Wharton to his
beloved daughter Brunhilde everybody is
weeping in the audience you know and
here's he creates conflict situation a
little bit like Shakespearean again
again but everybody knows somehow and
now he gives this music he comes from
underneath practically what what you do
with that he comes to me something where
you cannot defend yourself it's a kind
of suggest is very suggestive musically
and it's always overwhelming yep it
never tries to explain the things or it
just gets you in combination with this
psychic situation family situation
mm-hmm it must be something like this
hypnotic often used yeah irresistible
you can't you can't resist it quite
actually yeah he tries not to argue but
to convince you immediately overwhelm
you yeah it's like if you're under water
yeah
sensuality is a very important very
essential world erotic sit Thomas Mann
used coined this verse it's interesting
to hear you I mean to hear you know
Richard Wagner's granddaughter telling
me this because I I come from a
background where you know Wagner's music
was 100 miles away it was it was just
not part of where I came from and I
could never have imagined being caught
up in vogner being captivated by it and
I have in recent years I have to be able
to answer this question much more than
I've given some of this music so yeah
you're true true I never could really
get a distance yeah I've given it a lot
of thought I have to say but I've also
and there there's the word but vogner
was a genius his music is irresistible
and I think a lot of people agree very
relevant today yeah but Richard Wagner
was also a rabid anti-semite mm-hmm he
was a man who had many other ugly traits
in his character yeah his music is still
banned in Israel today yeah and you have
said nevertheless despite all that you
have said this endless moral outrage
over varnas character gets on my nerves
yeah it gets on your nerves he has been
born 200 years ago yeah he has left us
his music his work and I something is
getting on my nerves
that they treat him as if he were our
contemporary more or less yeah he has
lived in very different times he was an
anti-semite he hated the French also but
nevertheless he wrote down why he hated
the Jews and
yeah it's written down you know it's not
just the same there's evidence it's
progress and it's very concrete yeah so
we we must know what does it mean
anti-semitism
anti Judaism in his time yeah for
historian whoa we should try to turn it
like this and then we must ask a
question did this ugly traits enter his
works enter his operas and there has
been arguments arguments research and
research finally it comes out no because
if he had wanted to show us how ugly the
Jew is on stage it would have been able
to do this he didn't he didn't there are
constellations you know there are
characters environment that people do
view as caricatures people do view but
they are not characterized as Jewish so
if you understand certain stereotypes
certain constellations like blond
Siegfried and the ugly walls and so on
you can do I permit it absolutely
permitted to see through these disguise
mandir amendment and decipher it as
anti-semitic racist constellation but if
you're a naive approach our nowadays why
should you why should you I couldn't do
it it when I was a child for us for me
it was more fairytale corrupt characters
later on you're getting educated you
know how to see through these theatrical
disguises okay so that's that that's
that that's the music and I see your
line of argument beyond the music there
is also your family's relationship with
the Nazis with Adolf Hitler yeah from
what 1920 onwards very early in Hitler's
rise to power your family hosted and
supported and lionized and nourished
Adolphe Hitler yeah yeah this one this
is a fact
hmm yeah there is a nationalistic idea
german ideological heritage that comes
through the late vogner
yeah and is given over in the family and
they were German nationalists and this
has been reinforced they were not so
nozzles Ellison Nazis
yeah Nazis then so this is a line that
comes from the late vogner no doubt and
so the interpretation of Agnes work
works also from the side of the family
there in German ideology much more than
anything else you can interpret Wagner's
words also on the socialistic level if
she wants oh but they didn't they were
German ideologic interpretation that
came out of the family and there was the
bad luck of vinified Wagner she was born
British and as we know very often when
you change your identity your your
nationality you become especially fierce
and she came to Germany her life and she
became more German and then she found
her Savior out of Italy in debt who
admired her Havana flirted with her
certainly and gave her support where he
could later on later in later you money
and then public yeah yeah and okay the
German people when won't voted for
Hitler this also sounds so this all
sounds very rational and rational it is
I mean this is it what you're saying is
all true but your father sat on Adolf
Hitler's lap your father was given a car
by Adolf Hitler for his for his 18th
birthday your father was a member of the
Nazi Party and you must like all but I'm
interested in you as a sort of as
somebody who's typical of your
generation not somebody from your family
you must have gone to school
and being shown all the films that
people were shown at German schools at
the time about what happened in the
concentration camps and all this and you
must have made a link between your
grandmother your father so Hitler and
you yeah I'll tell you where the link is
that's not really a link we saw these
films who went to our grandmother and
asked her to come along with us into the
films she could learn something about
history mm-hmm about whom she had been
with this is Winifred again this is
benefit again she said I wouldn't go is
all American propaganda films so we
walked out and this was in a break with
my grandmother because what I tried to
finish the sentence
it wasn't unusual that they were Nazis
Hitler was elected he loved Wagner and
vinified headnote he couldn't she she
would would have been unthinkable that
she closed her doors when he when he
rose yeah we have to see it as
historians also but back to your link
that you order so there was a break we
could separate from our grandmother but
when we when we were growing up we did
not think of separating of our parents
because my father had gone into
opposition he - his mother - Nazism
he could not speak about it openly he
was too much involved as you just told
us so his mouth was shut in a way but he
acted as an artist he did what he could
in his Mickey on stage purifying the
scene getting away with any old Wagner
tradition included the Nazi tradition he
he did say he he took a distance of the
past so we thought well be on a good
side be on the good side there's the
criminal it's our grandmother
it was an easy was a little bit too easy
it's later only much later we learned
about the facts of his - natural
involvement in the Nazi regime he grew
up and it always came by he was a friend
of the family
and then my father was a very introvert
person there was a sister Freedland who
was not introvert who had Jewish friends
who went abroad and she opposed to
Hitler openly at the time my father did
not he was too close to his mother he
was he wanted also to come to power in
by heart and it was kind of protector of
the young man okay yeah the
constellation is devilish and the more
he suffered after the war there may be
one more question on this complex but it
is a question that I've asked myself for
a long time and I'm very fortunate to
having you here and you can possibly
give me an answer there are a lot of
historians who say that the Varginha
family is still keeping very important
documents under lock and key that
historians who are trying to document
the period really should have access to
and the question that arises from that
is do you believe that there are still
skeletons in the cupboard I don't really
believe that when one day the members of
my family in question here will render
their documents I don't think that this
will change the image that we have of
the relationship the Nazis and the
vagueness maybe there are two more
postcards from Hitler to vinified yeah
but I honestly I cannot imagine that
this would really bring forth things
that changes again something okay that's
a fair assessment we will have to wait
you see it might be a long time before
we actually get there because the
evidence is so strong already yeah if
you find one or two letters more maybe
to some part a Guinness some more
letters but remember
remember I don't think this will change
the image and our knowledge about the
close relationship maybe some more
details
Sonne Kovac now you were in charge of
the Vimal festival for ten years you've
now been at the helm in Bonn for a short
period of time but you're looking to the
future I suppose an American at this
stage would ask you there's a wonderful
American phrase what do you bring to the
table
do you do is it your name and your
networking capacities or is it more than
that I think it's more than that just by
very wishful thinking but to get good
programming interesting program priming
excuse me interesting programming match
to bond not only stars stars are
wonderful musicians no doubt but I think
you should shift also your attention
sometimes to a more elaborate program a
more coherent program which is difficult
to realize when you engage big
orchestras on tour they have their fixed
programs but what a war was
characteristic for my work in Vemma is
the kind of dramaturgical knitting
together a coherent programs on all
kinds and theater in towns in discussion
and cinema and in great music I like to
do this I will try to realize a little
bit of this in bond also even though the
main main dish will be the big
orchestras will be be chosen and another
main dish will be the education program
well this has been had been built up by
my predecessor in a marvelous way it's a
very rich education program and also
with the help of Deutsche Welle
cooperating cooperating we could realize
the big campus project yeah that means
not only getting over here o beetles out
of the country as a kind of ambassador
of the best Germany we have you can't do
this with Varla you know but also to
import young orchestras from
all science of the world that's a I love
watching youth orchestras when they're
playing because they have a completely
different kind of enthusiasm from the
but let's just go back to one of the
points you're making I mean you're
saying you're being very serious very
earnest very intellectual and and that's
all fine and I can imagine you come up
with very good very coherent programs
but what the what today's audiences want
is they want they want picnics and
public viewing and entertainment and
they want they want to be able to go
home after the weekend away and say I
saw a rattle conducting or I saw an
Saffy motor on stage and I was there big
stars and all that kind of stuff you
have to cater for that difficulty for
all festivals for all high classical
festivals today you know there's the
popular mainstream the digital digital
cultures and there's the elitist why
classical concerts where people are
getting older and older we know about
this and a lot is being done to build
bridges yeah and there will be also not
only the educational program but also
like a popular channel let's say to this
festival which is yeah you can't get the
young people otherwise mm-hmm and you
need I'm not running after young people
but you need them because I mean we
heard in that report you know your your
audiences are aging when I when I go to
the Opera House's here in Berlin when I
go to the concert halls in Berlin I look
around me and I'm really glad that this
state I'm living in is subsidizing this
art for me but that you know we're at
work yeah sort of
yeah middle class slightly sort of
elderly people not we're not 20 years
old I know everybody talks about it yeah
but try to be an historian for a moment
it has always been like this you know we
are we our culture grew out of the
little court cultures there were always
a minority of Oya of our society and our
tower endeavor must be today to build
bridges to the young and a lot of them
is
elsewhere you won't get in the big
popular and the concerts they are not
designed for big audiences no yeah
there's chamber music there's orchestral
music even if you have loudspeaker
boosters you would do harm to the music
so you can't have both you can do what
we all do you know the mediating
business the education business we do
much more than at my youth time they did
nothing we were curious to know we came
yeah now we have to try to find them but
if there's no parental home somewhat
cultures if they are not nothing is
being done it schools first pour
festivals cannot take up everything that
is that is should be done by the states
or on Indian individual level although
it's interesting because you're talking
about young audiences and when I do go
to Opera quite a lot and I go to
symphony concerts and a symphony
concerts I find it still quite a sort of
a stiffy sort of a stuffy sort of above
average age audience often what I go to
the Opera it's quite interesting how
many sort of people in their 20s are
turning up they find opera funny there
are stories being told yeah there is
blood and love and whatnot and very
often the metal send the stage directors
they like Axl to transform an old plot
that plays in Venice let's see today in
Afghanistan or somewhere mm-hmm so this
may be they try to attract young people
by by living our prom make their made
actual references just tell me one thing
when you you go to buy write regularly
still yeah yeah despite the fact that
you're not part of the sort of the
system did the set up the institution
yeah when you're sitting there on those
famously uncomfortable wooden seats
which are very sort of it tight yeah
and it's not very well the the it's not
comfortable yeah but you always think
this music from your great-grandfather
yeah what do you feel well I'm so at
home at this house yeah hmm
for me this is quite natural to sit
there I know it's yeah it's very
uncomfortable but I ask myself why do
people come and this for the Germans the
pleasure in the arts or in Opera in
music in bargainers music is it combined
to to stress to physical stress so that
you can walk out and say this was
something but you don't really mean the
arts but you mean what you achieved
yourself in this sporty manner even very
very funny phenomena because in giant
born you are very comfortable exactly
you have your pick nits it's everything
is very human eye but this is stopped in
mid-sentence there we're gonna have to
leave it there yeah yeah thank you very
much for sharing all those observations
with us your enthusiasm that is I'm
afraid you're locked with Mika vogner I
told you that she's a remarkable woman
with a remarkable story I think you've
you'll agree now if you've enjoyed her
company as much as I have do come back
next week until then bye bye punches
you